[Music]
kurodu is a community illegal
the parents here don't believe in
education they just want their kids to
just sell stuff
but then i saw how much they loved
dancing and how it was really changing
their lives and so i realized how much
impact dance would be in the life of
these kids
i use my passion for dancing to help
most of these kids who are from poor
homes
[Music]
my name is shayi olu only
jim carter's realize is my apartment
that i rented out and then i had the
kids come stay with me
we do mostly like afrobeats that's what
influences it just some of those that
when you're just here you just want to
you just want to move to it
in the morning they actually do like an
exercise routine just to strengthen
their core so that when they are dancing
you can beat their strength if they
school morning then you go to school
it's during the holidays they read they
do um video rehearsals
everybody just has a different story and
now they are
[Applause]
[Music]
here when i was between nine and ten
sometimes we would sleep on the street
sometimes we sleep in people's car
garage
i started dancing i think when i was ten
when you are dancing you get to be free
you get to forget whatever it is that
you are going through and just let go
when i was growing every single time i
used to reach somebody i just helped me
sometimes i would dream that jennifer
lopez would just come from nowhere and
just pick me up when i just found myself
in the position i decided that you don't
know i couldn't get anyone to rescue me
i think i'm going to rescue other kids
and just be that source of hope to other
kids out there
i've gone from seeing kids who couldn't
read they are now reading they can read
properly now some of them were low
self-esteem wouldn't think that they
could become anything now it's easier
for them to look at the future and
believe that they can have something
i want the world to see africa and
nigeria in a positive way everything
that we do i try to always relate it
back to where we are from just reminding
the kids that this is who we are where
africans were nigerians and everybody
needs to always remember that no matter
where they see us
dance finale did give them hope and help
them see themselves knew that he never
saw themselves
[Music]
you